Você sabia que os Estados Unidos
acabaram de aprovar um remédio para
autismo, que é basicamente uma
supervitamina? Pois é, olha só essa
notícia. O FDI americano aprovou
leucovorina para criança com autismo. E
veja bem, não é uma droga nova complexa,
é uma forma turbinada do ácido fólico,
aquela vitamina B9 que todo mundo
conhece. E qual que é a diferença? Essa
versão consegue chegar no cérebro onde o
folato comum não cansaria. Os estudos
mostraram melhora na fala, na interação
social e nas habilidades cognitivas em
crianças que tinham anticorpos
bloqueando receptores de folato no
cérebro. Olha, muitos casos de autismo t
a ver com questões metabólicas
nutricionais que podemos corrigir. Não é
só comportamento, é bioquímica cerebral.
A leucovorina nada mais é do que uma
ferramenta para consertar uma via
metabólica quebrada. E o mais
interessante, estamos falando de uma
vitamina otimizada, não de uma droga
sintética pesada. É a prova de que
precisamos olhar o autismo de uma forma
mais ampla, tratando as causas, não são
sintomas. Na prática, isso abre portas
para investigarmos deficiências
nutricionais e problemas de metilação em
crianças com teia. Yeah.